please go ahead no I think we're behind
you I promise I can I cannot tell a lie
so every we'll get you next okay okay
well thank you so much mr. Pratt tonight
my question I have two questions the
first one is on testing you talked about
the idea that first it was ventilators
now it's testing you seem to maybe
possibly be implying that talking about
testing is a personal attack on you can
you explain why you think testing
talking about testing is a personal
attack given that the access detecting
it's been an issue for a long time
there's bipartisan outcry still today
that there's not enough testing why do
you think it's a personal attack on you
well it's not a bipartisan it's mostly
partisan but more importantly than
mostly partisan it's incorrect you have
you have the experts look at these maps
I mean you have the maps with so many
different locations in the case of as an
example Governor Hogan he didn't really
know he really it was very obvious to
any of those listening on the call today
even though you weren't supposed to be
on it I'm sure that some of you were or
representatives were he really didn't
know about the federal laboratories
would you say that's correct my he
didn't know he didn't know and Mike
doesn't like to get into this stuff he's
less controversial than I am but he
didn't know about it and if he didn't
know about it he would have been happy
no we've done a really good job in
testing now with that being said we have
tests coming out perhaps over the next
two weeks that will blow the whole
industry away now a lot of people love
the Abbott test so do I you know the
Abbott test is great because it's bull
it's they touch they put it in in five
minutes you have the problem is that
doesn't do massive numbers like the big
machine but the big machine takes a day
takes a day and a half you know with
delivery and everything else but we have
tremendous testing tremendous testing
capability remember this we've tested
more than any country in the world by
far in fact I think I read where if you
add up every other country in the world
we've tested more but remember this
we're dealing in politics we're dealing
with a thing called November 3rd of this
year do you know what November 3rd
represents right
you know better than anybody in the room
November third of this year's called the
presidential election no matter what I
do no matter where we go no matter how
well we do no matter what if I came up
with a tablet you take it and and this
plague is gone they'll say Trump did a
terrible job
terrible terrible because that's their
soundbite that's the political soundbite
they know the great job we've done but
with all of that being said and and also
there is a thing that somebody could
talk to if they want but I don't want to
bore you with it not everybody believes
you should do so much testing you don't
need so much we're talking about maximum
x'p the reason that the democrats and
some others maybe because they don't
know they want maximum because they want
to be able to criticize because it's
almost impossible to get to the maximum
number and yet we've been able to do it
already
but with that and you'll be seeing this
over the next i think over the next
couple of weeks or sooner we have a test
if it comes out it'll revolutionize the
whole world of testing it'll be it'll be
something really special so i don't view
it as personal at all
what I do say is it's something that's
not fair to thousands of people that
have done such a good job his family got
sick they went to a funeral in mid-march
if he said mainly because the president
wasn't taking it serious and he said if
the President had had a mask on if he
was saying we should stay home then I
would have stayed home and just as
family members were sickened because
they were what they were listening to
you and do you feel like or are you
concerned that downplaying the virus
maybe gonna feel sick and a lot of
people love Trump right a lot of people
love you seem all the time right I guess
I'm here for a reason you know to the
best of my knowledge I want and I think
we're gonna win again I think we're
gonna win in a landslide but just so you
understand you're talking about March
right and yet excuse me excuse me I know
I understand and yet in January a
certain date you know the date better
than I do we put on a band of China
where China can't come in
and before March we put on a ban on
Europe where Europe can't come in so how
could you say I wasn't taking it
seriously do you know I put on a ban on
China before anybody in this country
died I put on a band and so you tell me
Nancy Pelosi was having she wanted to
have a street party in Chinatown in San
Francisco at the end of February that's
a month later and then they tell me it's
only a political talking point but you
feed into it because you too good a
reporter to let that happen really you
are a good reporter you're too good a
reporter to let that happen remember
this so at the end of January I put on a
band people that were in that room will
tell you that I think there were 21
people I was the only one of the whole
room that wanted to do it fortunately I
was the one that counted for that
purpose we put on a band because I was
reading bad things about China World
Health Organization should have told us
but I was reading it with or without
them they should her no no they had to
do is read it they didn't have to even
be there but they tried to cover up for
China world health covered up for China
but no no wait but you can't say this
your I put on a band in other words I
stopped China from coming to the United
States
I stopped Europe from coming into the
United States long before the March date
that you're talking about so people
should say I acted very early that was a
very hard thing to do doing that was a
very hard thing I didn't want to do that
but I did it because I thought and
doctor ouchy said that by doing it
president Trump saved tens of thousands
of lives so I did take it very seriously
in February and in March and there are
some I don't know I don't know but
rallies I really don't know about
rallies I know one thing in February I
haven't left the White House in months
except for a brief moment to give a
wonderful ship the comfort in March
ally I'm sorry I hold a rally did I hold
a rally let me tell you in January when
I did this yet virtually no cases and no
deaths and yet I put it on so how could
I not
why was Nancy Pelosi right Nancy Pelosi
is holding a street fair she wants a
street fair in San Francisco
in Chinatown to prove you know what the
purpose of it was to prove that there's
no problem many other politicians did
the same thing I want to prove while I
was no of course not no no no - people
are amazed at how early I acted and I
did act early with that being said it's
very hard to say let's close down the
greatest economy in the history of the
world
I had it closed down I and everybody
else that works with me and and 300 and
close to 350 million people built the
greatest economy in the history of the
world best employment numbers best stock
market numbers best numbers in virtually
every category even good manufacturing
numbers the previous administration said
manufacturing was dead for our country
even great manufacturing numbers and you
know what I did that and somebody walked
into my office since it sir you can have
to close down the Academy you're gonna
have to close the country but you know
what I say to you we're gonna rebuild it
and we're gonna rebuild it better and
it's going to go faster than people
think
I built it once I built it a second time